[Narrator:] Asian influenza spreads rapidly.
It can strike you and your entire family at
the same time,
but it doesn't have to happen
if you and your family are vaccinated against
Asian influenza.
Get this protection in time.
See your doctor or health department now.
[Narrator:] Vaccination is your only protection
against Asian influenza.
Be sure you and every member of your family
have this protection in time.
Once the disease strikes your community,
it is too late for vaccination.
See your doctor or health department now.
[Narrator:] For the first time in history,
we are forewarned of a possible epidemic.
You can help prevent the spread of Asian influenza
and protect the health of your family
by vaccination against Asian influenza.
Don't wait. See your doctor or health department
now.
[Narrator:] If you need to be on the job every
working day,
you can't afford any unnecessary illness.
Asian influenza can make you too sick to work.
Don't risk it.
Take the time to be vaccinated against Asian
influenza
and stay on the job full-time.